this is Liz Gilbert hi thanks doing -
where did you get that button hey some
bookstore that is exactly what I need I
need something like that because I don't
listen I never have my mom used to
always call me Little Miss Chatty Cathy
because I just ramble I am a Rambler I
am rambling now that's actress Julia
Roberts of course playing Elizabeth
Gilbert and Eat Pray Love the movie was
adapted from Gilbert's 2006 memoir of
the same name her books have sold more
than 20 million copies worldwide
Gilbert's newest novel city of girls
explores the life of a young woman
coming of age in New York City's
glamorous and sometimes scandalous
theater world in the 1940s Elizabeth
Gilbert good morning welcome good
morning you have said that if you want
to write an honest memoir write a novel
Oh busted you will learn a lot about my
youth in this book yeah what will we
learn oh my goodness you set me up but
let's just go for it this is a book
about very promiscuous young women
behaving very recklessly and
experiencing and testing the limits of
their power
did you set it in the 40s I set it in
New York City in the 1940s because I
feel like that is the most impossibly
glamorous moment of New York history and
that's somebody who's loved New York
forever I wanted to just play in that
world of like midtown Manhattan the
Great White Way the music the shows and
setting in the theater world meant that
I got to amp up that glamour even more
you've also called it a champagne
cocktail how do you put a cocktail into
into prose well what I said to my editor
is when I turned it in was I want people
to have to knock this back and one gulp
and not be able to stop reading because
there's there's I tried to put suspense
in it and action in it to kind of keep
you unable to turn away and maybe you
leave feeling a little drunk
accomplished I mean your first line of
the book in the summer of 1940 when I
was 19 years old and an idiot grabbed my
attention but what's so fascinating to
me about this play about this about this
book it's about female desire and
consequences of that it's certainly
about friendship but it's a story and
then there's a play within the story and
then there are reviews within the story
then there are lyrics within the story
and I keep thinking you had to write all
of that I got into keep track of that
you've got to write a very point we'll
take it yeah and that you had to keep
track of all those different storylines
yeah and the entire book takes place
within the framework of a letter that
she's writing back to somebody it's
written from the point of view of a
woman in her 90s and she's just gotten a
letter from someone saying I want to
know what you were to my father yeah
back in the day and the whole book is an
answer to that and then within it
there's a play and there's oh but for me
that's so much fun because I got to
experiment with so many different kinds
of form and making up Broadway show
tunes and the lyrics to that was that's
such a gasps he spent six years writing
this book and you said that writing it
was kind of like learning you have to
learn especially and about another time
which was like learning a foreign
language yeah when this is this is the
second book that I've written that's a
historical novel and it is true that it
is like learning another language to the
point where you immerse yourself for
years that was six months of six years
of research yeah um you you immerse
yourself in it so that by the time you
sit down to write you're not
overthinking you just know how these
people spoke you know how they dressed
you know what they ate you know what
things cost so that you just disappear
yourself into that world you know that
one point you said at some point a
woman's life she gets tired of being
ashamed yeah and she just wants to be
free to be herself yes and I wonder how
that applied to you because during
before this book you lost your partner
ray oh I remember reading meaning
meeting ray on and you went through a
very difficult time with that Liz so
your personal life is so fascinating to
me how can I ask the question without
being implied or indelicate I've written
six memoirs ask whatever you want
Sheryl will break up with your marriage
meet a guy fall in love with him then
you fall in love with Ray oh yeah ray
unfortunately has passed away and now
you were recently with a man how do we
understand about Liz Gilbert help us
understand it's not about a bit I also
say it's none of our business
I made it your business I mean I can't
sit here and say it's not your business
when I'm on Instagram telling you my
life is love just love is that what we
should love who you love is definitely
it and and and it never occurred to me
it would never occur to me to
discriminate and love based on gender I
fell in love with Raya I didn't fall in
love with a body I know I felt she was
your best friend for many years and when
she was diagnosed with terminal cancer I
was forced you know with the reckoning
of
her immediacy of her death to to have to
bring that forward and say there's
there's a name for this love that I have
for this person and that is that is
she's the love of my life yeah yeah
we're bringing her we're bringing Luce
back we are bringing yes she's gonna
stick around or four before we go we
have to go right now so we have time
before that okay sit here as long as you
let's say tomorrow
go to CBS this morning calm to read an
excerpt it's a volume you will enjoy
there's a tall